my name is Kelly Ormond and I am a
professor in the Department of Genetics
here at Stanford I'm also on faculty at
the Stanford center for biomedical
ethics my background is training as a
genetic counselor so that's a two-year
master's degree I did my training at
Northwestern University in Chicago and I
spent the first several years of my
background as a clinical genetic
counselor at the University of Vermont
working in prenatal genetic speedy a
trek genetics and adult neurology
genetics I also did teratology and then
I moved to Northwestern where I did some
prenatal genetic counseling for several
years and also began directing the
training program there and I came here
to Stanford in 2007 and my primary job
has been directing the masters level
training program for genetic counselors
here as well as doing some biomedical
ethics research around genetics you know
people always wonder personalized
medicine what does it really mean find a
couple things that are really relevant
to you and whether it's for your own
personal learning or for your employment
to really understand some of the
exciting stuff that comes along with
personalized medicine because it really
is great I wouldn't work in genetic
counseling if I didn't think it was
great but I also want you to come away
really knowing that there are
significant limitations at this point
and that there are social aspects to all
venues of genetic testing and you should
really be thinking seriously about all
of that because every person interprets
it differently
you